What's up everyone? [we're] here to talk to you today about a thing we've been working on called tether
I'm sure all you guys have watched this video and been like where did this come from
What is this about we're about to tell you the story of what this is all about?
[right] after we finished creating our modern warfare series
We had our sights set at creating another long-form web series that first concept was tether created nearly two years ago
So he created a bunch of different storylines made this whole universe bunch of concept art trying to set up this world
So we could make a neat web series in but at the end of the day things didn't really work out and we instead [focused]
On our YouTube channel making the bi-weekly content that you guys are so familiar with
So as you guys saw we made [Minecraft]. We made a bunch of stuff. I'm a dubstep gunz all that stuff last year
Until, we were re-approched to create this series again.
That is where this particular episode comes in.
So this is what we made, a pilot for Tether a potential first episode that would give you guys a taste of what the full series could be like.
So Machinima now having grown in our channel having grown approached this again to try making a web-series one more time
We wrote a script came up with all this stuff for the pilot, but once again things didn't work out
But at this point
It is something we put so much time into in a world that we had spent so much time crafting that we're like duck it
We're gonna do it anyways we want to make a short-film so you guys can at least see
what we were trying to try and make trying to make.
conjure out of thin air.
Now, you know actually making it is easier said than done. I mean the script requires tons of actors,
Tons of
Locations, vehicles, gunfights, VFX... just tons of stuff and that obviously required a budget
so what we decided to do is fund it out of our own pockets and
Make it ourselves, A True Corridor Digital production from the ground up
So as you guys can tell there's still a lot of mystery and
Unsolved enigmas in this world of Tether that we have not yet explained.
We don't know if were gonna make one more generally speaking.
It's whenever we go back to Minnesota for Christmas that we shoot an episode of Tether
This year if you guys really like this, and you want to see another one, we'll probably throw up a Kickstarter
So you guys can help us pull off one more [episode] to round out the world.
It's like Giving us a Christmas present that we then give back to you
After messing with it a little bit. So I hope you guys like tether now
I know, it's just a little taste of this giant world hopefully down the line. We make another one, and you guys like it
Yeah, and especially considering everyone's positive response to sync so far
We really wanted to give making another long-form narrative series a shot. Whether it's heather or something different, not sure
Kind of up to you, but either way make sure it something you guys want to watch so anyway section checking it out
Facebook, Twitter.. Social Media integration